it was a word that ripped a hole in the
universe yeah yeah yeah really
so was it yanny or Laurel we asked the
experts we're gonna do the Laurel and he
auntie debate with three three-year-old
twins what's your name okay all right so
we're gonna press play and see who hears
what it's good at lead to war this guys
would be such a big deal even the White
House got involved its Laurel but I
could deflect and divert to Annie
Sarah it's been reported that you here
Laurel how do you respond
clearly you're getting your information
from CNN because that's fake news oh I
hear Kofi
so
[Applause]
here's the thing that video about Laurel
and Yanni now becomes a lorilynn yanny
in itself meaning if you like Trump
you'll actually laugh but if you're a
host at CNN you'll say how can you laugh
when children don't have socks and
Quercus fan so this silly audio puzzle
maybe the greatest metaphor for media
bias ever think about this when Trump
says something what do you hear a joke
but the media they hear racism and when
you hear Trump describe ms-13 as animals
what did the media hear the President of
the United States saying these are not
people they're animals it is a
disgusting way to talk about human
beings he does things like all
immigrants animals he was just talking
about ms-13 good enough no not good
enough it is a very slippery slope when
you start dehumanizing people this way
it's what the Nazis did but she is the
model of civility back off you creep
I'll use the line please don't do this
it really annoys me I'm so happy so the
media gets it wrong but why should they
care Trump is mean and evil he's like
dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde - the dr. Jekyll
essentially he's just mr. Hyde but this
is what happens when you're so consumed
by Trump hate that you can't think
straight
recently the Daily Caller asked people
who would you rather date a felon or a
trump supporter a majority said felon
now they're lying but the great thing
about surveys you can do that if they
really meant it they'd head to a local
prison go straight to death row and
snuggle a serial killer you'll die but
you show Trump but the media is worse
here's a tweet from John Harwood quote
however repugnant their actions ms-13
gang members they're human beings in my
humble opinion no he's right ms-13 they
are humans but John so was Hitler
so was Charles Manson Jeffrey Dahmer
carrot top so when your fact applies to
everyone it's no longer meaningful oh
yes
yes he killed your family but both of
you enjoyed Star Wars that doesn't work
Nancy disagrees when the President of
the United States says about
undocumented immigrants these aren't
people these are animals you have to
wonder it does he not believe in the
spark of divinity the dignity and worth
of every person I think I just realized
the MS and ms-13 stands for
misunderstood keep talking
I wanted to keep talking cuz if this is
the direction the Democrats want to go
just reelect Trump now you're becoming
the cartoon we always thought you were
but at least the media is coming to
grips with their own delusions I do
think that we have to acknowledge that
there is so much more happening in the
world then Donald Trump and we in the
media are essentially all Trump all the
time let me express my own addiction as
well you know my wife and I we find
ourselves our pillow talk is tonight is
about trying to Trump right now so yes
he's addicted to Trump but the first
step to recovery is admitting you have a
problem and now there's a place to kick
the habit we've heard about it in the
media we have to acknowledge that there
is so much more happening in the world
then Donald Trump but the first step to
healing is admitting it
Trump addict before it's too late my
wife and I we find ourselves our pillow
talk is so nice about Trump terrible
that's right it is terrible but now
there's hope thanks to the brian Stelter
Institute for the Trump addicted we
understand the need for a safe space to
talk about your unhealthy obsession with
the president I stay up all night
waiting to see what Trump's gonna tweet
next I haven't slept in four hundred
eighty three days let's see mr. Janeiro
what about you you know I watch these
Trump rallies on TV I just think but the
more fun they have angrier I get upset
well the good news is this is not a real
medical condition and grow a pair and
get on with their life
feel better now a little bit little bit
the brian Stelter institute for the
trump addicted so you can stop whining
forever
it's so like every other week the media
chases words and overlooks deeds but I
get it it's frustrating they've been
obsessing over Russian collusion and it
seems to be shrinking away you know what
the collusion story really is for the
media it's like the press bought a roast
chicken on a Sunday and by Tuesday
they're down to nothing but bones and
gristle true the roasted chicken of
collusion is bear if only the media had
a roast chicken collusion regenerator
and Tom you're on in five minutes I know
but my rustic illusion chicken look it's
almost gone how am I gonna talk about
Russia without my delicious rotisserie
chicken of Russian collusion I mean you
don't know about the roast chicken
collision regenerator no tell me more
it's right over there
has it work the roast chicken collusion
regenerator uses hysteria convection
technology to regrow your collusion
chicken ensuring there's always fresh
meat to the story it even comes in a
compact desk unit for companies that
rely on Russian collusion chicken for
their day-to-day business
there we go 30 seconds whoa that is some
fresh collusion chicken right they say
give a man a roast chicken he'll collude
for a day
give him a collusion chicken regenerator
he'll collude for a lifetime
we'll be able to pick at this forever
Thanks collusion chicken regenerator
order now and we'll throw in a free
stormy Daniel spatula no matter what the
news picks up you can always flip at the
storm
I'm pretty sure I wasn't high when I
came up with that
[Applause]
let's welcome tonight's guest he's got
more tales than a petting zoo author of
up in the air and columnist at Harper's
Magazine Walter Kirn if you are feeling
blue seek out dr. drew host of the radio
show dr. drew midday live dr. Drew
Pinsky her favorite children's book is
The Omen NASA review reporter cats in
his favorite snack is the actual Milky
Way former WWE Superstar my massive
psychic iris you've been traveling the
country I haven't seen you for months
you're not even watching any news yeah
I'm sure you don't even know what I'm
talking about the Laurel whatever what
do you take about the gulf between the
media and the public here you were
you've just seen okay in late February I
left on an eight-week road trip across
the south and southwest I determined
that I would watch no news not go on the
internet and not listen to the radio the
last words I heard before leaving were
stormy Daniels and Robert Mueller yeah
eight weeks away I turned back on the
radio the first words I heard were
Robert Mueller and stormy day I called
myself Trump Van Winkle
apparently except for aging slightly
America is doing exactly the same thing
every day which is obsessing about non
stories while North Korea the nuclear
eise's the Iran deal gets ripped up
there's not just some news out there
yeah there's like the biggest news of
our lifetime yes
don't go away anymore dr. drew okay
let's get to that this laurel yanny
thing explains everything in life and
that scares me and I think you might
agree with me I do agree with you you're
a Scot out of accolade who pointed that
out it's a tear in the universe it
points this thing out that we can both
all hear the same thing we can listen to
the same thing and hear two completely
different things the MS sir 13 the
discussion was a perfect example that
and people get heated about it it's so
weird to me they really like thee but
you saw those twins everybody upset
about but I'm telling you what the
metaphor that I like even better that
you pointed out a minute ago was a trump
addiction yeah I know if you want to get
into that but the media needs to go cold
Trump yes there's really no other way
there's no other way to deal with it you
are the expert I'm telling you that's
the obsession they're life's falling
apart there's progression they tried the
same thing over and over again right dr.
drew here's the thing about addiction if
you go cold turkey without giving your
life over to a higher power you're just
gonna be angry frustrated and resentful
no they're gonna be they're gonna be a
dry Trump yeah and so and so the dry
Trump may may be worse than using
right no that's exactly right Trump yeah
I'm amazed that this is the first time
that word those words have never been
uttered together yes the higher power of
appeal is Warren Katz what do you make
of the media that's whole kerfuffle if
you will over animals well it's so
interesting because so many media wake
up every morning trying to think of what
negative story can I put out there about
Trump and this week the best they could
do was that he thinks that gang members
are not good people I always thought
that if somebody rapes a bunch of people
and rips their limbs off and murders
them that it's not it's like not a big
deal if you don't like that yeah yes I
really always thought that that wasn't
controversial but apparently it is no no
no you're being judgmental
I got dare you call rapists and
murderers animals all right Tyrus bring
it home well first of all I I got to see
him on his trip yeah and he he looked
like he had been in some trouble like he
was weird he's scared was like 12 when
he came to my house and I was like whoa
Walter crazy murderer like he looked
weird but he didn't he didn't watch the
news or anything we watched jaws and he
talked during the whole movie
what no no but this is what is so great
about him I didn't mind it like the food
was explain to me how different he's
like on this part this is he's chasing
his moby dick and he basically narrated
jaws too you know and uh when he left I
said he looked like a filthy animals
[Laughter]
he's gonna everything's going to call on
me you know it's I just think that we
live in a world today it's sad or maybe
good I don't know if I was ms-13 I'm
apparently a better person than the
president
I guess that's cool in certain according
to did used to be frowned upon yeah
if I wrote it on my job application
ms-13 I'm not gonna get the job and
probably submit in a uniform are gonna
show up now it's reality now they're
gonna talk about your spark of humanity
[Laughter]
13 members let's all get together and
hug see how that works out yeah all
right I am the spark plug of humanity